Whenever you listen to the radio,
watch TV, or browse the Internet,
you are bombarded with
crises of all types.
While these crises, political, health,
social, play out on a global stage,
many of us struggle with
crisis situations of our own.
Today, I look forward to our
discussion of crisis communication.
I'm Matt Abrahams, and
I teach strategic communication at
Stanford Graduate School of Business.
Welcome to Think Fast,
Talk Smart, the podcast.
I am so
excited to be joined by David Demarest,
who is a lecturer of
management at the GSB.
Prior to the GSB, David served as
White House Communications Director for
President George HW Bush.
And was a member of
the White House senior staff.
Next, David served as
Executive Vice President and
Director of Corporate Communications
at Bank of America.
And then as Executive Vice President for
Corporate Relations and
Brand Management at Visa International.
Later, he became Stanford's Vice President
for Public Affairs and
oversaw communications and
government relations and events.
Beyond teaching at the GSB,
David is finishing his book about what
life is like working in the White House.
Welcome, David.
>> Hey, thanks, Matt.
It's great to be with you,
this is going to be fun.
>> There's so [LAUGH] much for
us to discuss, shall we get started?
>> You bet.
>> So question one,
when it comes to crises,
you've had to deal with a few for sure.
Can you highlight one or
two that you've dealt with, and
any learnings that have come
from those experiences?
>> Well, sure.
One day, I came into the office and
one of my staff told me that we had,
due to a data processing center foulup,
that we had lost
1.2 million automatic credits and
automatic deposits.
That's a lot of transactions to lose.
And they were all in California.
And it meant that people's mortgage
payments weren't going to happen.
It meant that their payroll,
their paycheck didn't get deposited,
things like that.
It meant that a lot of insufficient
funds checks might be going out,
and it was a incredible mess.
This was a formula for
a whole lot of very angry customers.
>> Sure.
>> Well, what we were able
to do was to disaggregate,
what were the accounts that might
have been more easily remediated?
By virtue of if somebody had a Bank of
America account for their payroll deposit,
and a Bank of America account for
their mortgage payment,
we could intercept that
transaction in between and fix it.
What it meant was that we could get those
transactions down to a manageable level,
of the ones that we really couldn't
address in the short-term.
So by the end of the day,
we had narrowed it down to about
69,000 insufficient funds notices
that were going to go out.
So that meant that our focus could be,
okay,
what are we going to
do about those people?
And come up with a remedy for
them that made sense, and
get our apology notes out to them and
so forth.
It told me that you need to be able
to disaggregate the problem into its
component parts, and deal with
the parts that are most critical.
The second crisis I
would put out there was,
at Stanford, we had a laptop,
it was stolen.
And it contained a lot of
employee personal data,
like thousands of
employees' personal data.
We didn't know if it was stolen for
the data, or
if it was just stolen because it was
a laptop, that didn't really matter.
By the time we figured out
what was on the computer,
we knew that we had to do a public
announcement, too, as a notification.
But it was already late
in the day on Friday,
not the time when you want
to do a public announcement.
People think you're trying
to hide the information.
So our choice really was to do it then or
do it Monday.
Also on Monday, we'd have all the systems
in place, the toll free number,
what we're going to do about
identity theft and things like that.
We made the choice to
go on Friday at 6 PM.
And we did that because we
felt that people's trust
in us trumped the efficiency
of waiting until Monday.
That if anyone had their identity stolen
over the weekend, and they found out
that we knew about this breach, but
we didn't talk to them about it,
when we knew about it,
that would be a violation of the trust.
And we came down to
trust beats efficiency.
And in our communication,
we told people that we won't have
the toll free number set up until Monday.
We won't have the identity theft
remediation set up until Monday.
But we felt it was important to get
this information out as soon as we
knew what the circumstance was.
Because we didn't want to risk
someone not being able to take
an action on their own to
try to protect themselves.
>> Thank you for sharing those two,
I hear two lessons that you learned.
One is, in a big, complicated crisis,
it's to your advantage to break it
down into its constituent parts.
And it sounds like having a platform in
technology that can help you doesn't hurt
in that situation.
And then the other piece is to know your
values that you as an organization have,
and really challenge yourself
to live by those values.
And that must help be a guiding light.
>> I think too many organizations haven't
spent enough time really thinking about,
what would they do in a circumstance
that called upon them
to act without knowing all of
the details of the situation?
The pressure to act can be intense, and
that's why knowing your values is so
important.
Because it gives you
a beacon that can inform how
you're going to prioritize your actions.
>> So let me ask you the second question,
when communicating about a crisis,
what are some best
practices to keep in mind?
So when you're actually
sending the message out.
>> Yeah, I think the key here is that,
A, you gotta know what you don't know.
So you have to have kind of a catalogue of
information that you would like to know,
but maybe you don't know.
And how important is that information,
which leads to, don't speculate.
People speculate as to what might be the
case, not necessarily what is the case.
And then, you mentioned it earlier,
know your organization's values and
be guided by them.
Companies and organizations that have
a solid sense of who they are and
what they stand for.
They will be able to navigate
a crisis much more effectively than
those companies or
organizations that don't.
And I even tell my students this, Matt,
that if you know as a person what
your values are in this crazy
turbulent world that we live in,
you'll be able to navigate it a lot
better than to always be situational.
Finally, if there's a necessity for
apology, and often there is,
that apology has to be timely,
it's got to show true regret.
The organization has to take real
responsibility, in other words, ownership,
and if possible, provide a remedy.
And that's what we did in
the case of the stolen laptop.
We did provide a remedy to people,
which was identity theft protection, and
we did that quickly.
>> Thank you.
So I know you have some very specific ways
of thinking about audience engagement,
can you share what this looks like?
From your perspective?
>> I think that,
if we take Stanford as an example, but
it applies to pretty
much any organization.
All organizations have
multiple constituencies.
So in Stanford's case,
as you well know, we have students,
we have faculty,
we have donors, we have alumni.
We have the federal government,
who supplies us with $1 billion of
research every year, research funding.
We have the local community and so forth.
And so every organization has multiple
constituencies that care about
how the organization interacts with them,
some more than others.
So part of effective crisis management
is to have your finger on the pulse
of each one of those constituencies, and
what elements of the crisis are going to
be germane to each constituency,
to a greater or lesser degree.
So you start to have kind of
a stakeholder map, in a sense.
And then that allows you to know what
their concerns, what their fears are,
what their anger quotient might be-
>> [LAUGH]
>> If something has affected them very
directly.
And then the next step
is to go where they are.
You can't kind of sit back and
wait for them to come to you.
You have to go to them and
basically listen to them, ask for
their guidance as to what it
is that is of concern to them,
and how can they help
you meet their concerns?
So it's a much more proactive
engagement with stakeholders than to
simply tell people what you're doing and
then hope for the best.
>> Right, so your audience engagement
approach is similar to what we've
talked about prior on this podcast,
which is really,
know your audiences and understand
what it is that's important to them.
You're doing this very proactively,
in case something bad happens,
you know and
you're engaged with them prior.
And I also heard you say, be very
mindful of the different methodologies,
tools, and modalities with which
you can connect to them, and
leverage those so you can get your
messages out quickly and proactively.
I need to figure out how I can
affect the anger quotient of some of
the people that I live with in my house.
I'd like to reduce it a little bit, so
you've got me thinking about that for
sure.
We've talked about knowing your values,
knowing your corporate values.
We've talked about knowing your
audience and engaging them.
What are other things people can
do proactively to prepare for
a crisis that might arise?
>> Well, I'd say two things.
One, there are certain crises that
happen that are impossible to foresee
in very concrete terms.
And people aren't going to blame
Stanford if there's an earthquake.
What they will blame Stanford for
is if we were not prepared,
knowing that we're in an earthquake zone.
When I think about how
people think about crises,
I would suggest that
they do an inventory of,
what are the worst things that can happen,
and are we prepared for those things?
That's kind of part one, part two is,
don't drink the Kool-Aid.
A lot of people in organizations,
particularly leadership in organizations,
fall into the trap of
having an organizational bias
in favor of their organization.
We would never do that,
that is a dangerous trap.
We have to really get to
the facts of this case,
not just what are our preconceived notions
are about how good our organization is.
So you have to put yourself in
the shoes of someone who might have
an alternative view of your organization.
And that takes a little bit of hard
thinking, because I love working for
Stanford, and I've been there 16 years.
And it would be easy to think, well,
Stanford would never do this or
never do that.
Well, you've got to be able to put
yourself in the shoes of somebody who
might not think the way I do about
the university, or about my organization.
Sometimes you've gotta
think like an adversary, or
you have to think like a reporter.
And get yourself out of your comfort zone,
and
think in ways that a critic would think.
>> Very useful ideas, and in fact,
the last idea, about seeing the situation
from somebody else's perspective,
echoes something Bob Sutton shared
on our podcast in terms of team
meetings and group decision-making.
It can always benefit to have that
other perspective, and as you said,
to make sure that we're
not drinking the Kool-Aid.
And I think,
reflecting on what could go wrong,
while maybe depressing and concerning,
is a great thing to do, again,
in the name of being proactive and
preparation.
I'd like to change the topic a little bit.
You've spent a lot of your life
in the political world, and
you even teach a course on
political communication.
Looking at our current political
landscape, what advice do you have for
people who are trying to push a political
agenda that is important to them,
such as equity, energy, employment,
what advice might you have?
>> Yeah, we live in a remarkably
polarized environment, politically.
And it is very difficult
to have conversations,
metaphorically, across the aisle.
I think it's a tough
arena to navigate within.
But I think, if you're going to be
successful in trying to expand support for
your cause or your agenda, you have to
refrain from the temptation of being
too judgmental about those who might not
buy into what you're trying to sell.
And try to understand why, at a deeper
level, what's their concern about it?
And then make your case on their terms,
not yours.
You've gotta be thoughtful about
what avenue you can take to try to
break through some of, perhaps,
a rigidity of view on the other side.
But coming at it from a different angle
might be a little bit more persuasive
than simply jumping up and down and
saying, you're the devil incarnate.
The second half of that is, for
your supporters, it's really about moving
them from just being supportive to action,
and that means communicating urgency.
And how you communicate urgency
is to make sure that the see
the present-day merits of dealing
with a particular problem.
>> I really like how you
separate those two points.
The thing that really resonated
with me was the notion initially of
framing your point in the language and
the approach that the people you're
trying to convince are taking.
Rather than, it's my idea, and
you should see the world the way I do,
and try to appreciate the way
the other people see the world, and
put your communication
in that perspective.
And then the second part there,
this notion of urgency and driving action.
A lot of feel that, hey,
if I just share the information,
then it's inherent and
intuitive that action should follow.
But building that sense of urgency,
providing a pathway to action,
becomes very important.
>> Yeah, I remember back
at my Bank of America days,
the CFO was the person that
I ultimately reported to.
And when I would talk to him
about reputation management,
he'd kind of glaze over, because I wasn't
talking in a language that he could
really relate to So, I changed my
language to be one about risk management.
That was a concept that he
was very familiar with.
And that enabled me to have more
fruitful conversations with him about
the steps that we need to take when we
had to deal with reputational risk,
business risk,
financial risk, and so forth.
>> That last point you made about
the linguistics of it leads me to my next
question, which I know you and I share as
something that we are passionate about and
concerned with and teach about.
And that is the language you use and
the rhetoric involved in communication.
What thoughts do you have of
the importance of our words?
And does anything change as a result
of our communicating virtually,
rather than in-person?
>> Yeah,
those are really two great questions.
I love language, one of the modules in
my class is about language and rhetoric.
When you think about language and
you look at some,
I don't mean to get too esoteric here,
but the word strategy, for
example, comes from the Greek word
strategos, which means a general.
And the word tactics comes from the Greek
tactos, which means arranged in order.
The difference between strategy and
tactics then,
you kind of can bring to life by
talking about their derivation.
So, language is really what we
use to provide information,
to make an argument, to motivate behavior,
paint a picture, tell a story.
All of those things are essential
to bringing your issue to life.
And in other words, first building
an understanding of one's agenda.
I think, generally speaking,
those principles are applicable
to the virtual world.
Crisis management is, indeed,
much more complicated with the advent
of social media, we all know that.
Speed is essential because social
media creates a narrative so
quickly that people can mobilize faster.
Bad news travels faster than it used to.
Misinformation can spread like wildfire.
You have to understand the platforms
that we are all living with and
you've gotta communicate
to people in those spheres.
It used to be a rule,
kind of a communications rule,
that never repeat the accusation
that's made against you.
>> Yes.
>> Because that just
reinforces the accusation.
Well, in the virtual world,
if you have an answer to an accusation and
you don't put the accusation in your
talking points, or your FAQs, or whatever,
somebody searching for
that issue will never find your answer.
So, just using the right words so
that they are optimized for search.
We have to be sophisticated and know that
people are going to go to the web to find
out information about
a particular issue or crisis.
And you gotta use the language that
they would likely use in their search.
And so it's little things like that,
that I think can help us deal with
crisis management in the virtual world.
>> Absolutely, and the notion of
really thinking about wording and
the exact language you use is so powerful.
Most people focus on,
here's what I want to get across, but
if you spend just a little extra time of
thinking about, how do you use certain
words to help you get that information
across, it can be incredibly powerful.
I joke with people,
I have a 17-year-old son,
he's just gotten his driver's license,
he wants a car.
You cannot, today, David, buy a used car.
You can buy a certified previously owned
vehicle, but you can't buy a used car.
It's the same car, but calling it
a certified previously owned makes
it sound different and better and
they can charge more for it.
So, this notion of choosing language
wisely to help you further your goal,
I think, is really important, and
I know you and I both share that.
And I hadn't thought about how
detailed you have to get in your
thinking when it comes
to the virtual world.
And how people actually search for
the things that you're putting out there,
makes a lot of sense to me.
Before we end, I'd like to ask you the
same three questions I ask everyone who
joins me, are you up for that?
>> I'm ready.
>> All right, question number one.
If you were to capture the best
communication advice you ever received as
a five to seven word presentation
slide title, what would it be?
>> I'm not sure I can keep it to five to
seven words, but I think I can get close.
>> Okay.
>> Worry about being right
at the end of the meeting,
not at the beginning of the meeting.
>> Tell me more, but I like that a lot,
I'll let you have the extra words.
>> Well,
I think when it comes to leadership,
listening is more important than talking.
When you're leading a group of people, or
when you're meeting with
a group of stakeholders,
before you articulate your view, probably
better to listen to other people's views.
If you're leading a team of people and
you're in an authority role, if you lead
with what you think, you can bet your
bottom dollar that people will echo that.
I used to watch President Bush,
first President Bush in Cabinet meetings.
He never showed his cards when he
was talking about a policy issue.
He would always make the Cabinet talk
about what their views were, and
then he would go back to the Oval Office
and he'd make a decision.
If he had said, well, I don't think
this policy should be this or
that, every one of those
people would be saying, Mr.
President, you're so smart,
you're so brilliant.
That's just the nature of things, but
I think the point of it is listen first,
talk next.
>> Yes, words to live by, for sure.
Let me ask you question two, who is
a communicator that you admire and why?
>> I'll give you two, Gandhi and Lincoln.
>> Okay, you can share why?
>> Gandhi because he was able to
inspire a movement of hundreds
of millions of people
against colonialism in India.
And he did it in large ways
through communicating,
through his book about
seeking independence, and
then speaking and writing essays.
And Lincoln, who, I think, had he been
able to serve out his second term,
I think we would live in
a different country today.
All you have to do is read his second
inaugural address about with malice
towards none and charity for all.
It's a beautiful address.
>> Yes.
>> And he did it in so few words
just like the Gettysburg Address.
>> Mm-hm.
>> It was so powerful,
that he was able to capture what I
think was a hopeful vision of
what this country could be.
>> Absolutely, two wonderful communicators
who did amazing things for this world.
Last question, what are the three
ingredients, the first three ingredients,
that go into a successful
communication recipe?
>> Okay, I'll be too cute by half here,
context, context, context.
Knowing the contextual
environment of your circumstance,
whether it's a crisis, whether it's your
reputation, whether it's your brand.
Having a really rigorous
understanding of the contextual
environment is the foundation
of coming up with effective
strategies and
achieving your organization's goals.
>> Context is absolutely critical, as were
the topics that we discussed today, David.
I can think of no one better to help us
understand how to communicate in the times
we live in, than someone like yourself
who has experience in both crisis
management and crisis communication,
as well as political communication.
Thank you so much for your time, for
your insight, and for your advice.
>> Thanks Matt.
>> Thank you for listening to Think Fast,
Talk Smart, the podcast.
To learn more go to gsb.stanford.edu.
Please download other episodes,
wherever you find your podcasts.